as some of you may have noticed
we have covered on and even functions
before right
uh what what are odd and even functions
what's it tiny yeah it's
we would say that f of x
and f of minus x they're both the same
so if you take a value like five
and minus five
and you evaluate it you'll get the same
value right um and
odd functions
they have a different kind of symmetry
morning texas right so rather than
reflection or symmetry which is what you
get with an even function
we say you either point or rotational
symmetry for an odd function
okay now what am i talking about odd and
even polynomials
okay it's a little bit different there's
a there's a kind of new ones that i want
to get across to you but it's very
closely related to these okay so when
you hear
this phrase odd polynomial or even
polynomial
it's actually shorthand what it really
means is
for instance an odd polynomial
is a polynomial with an odd degree
okay like degree one three five seven
nine etc okay
um or it has an even degree
okay now let's think this through for a
second
if you have an odd polynomial okay
let's just consider the simplest kind of
odd polynomial
right so just degree one because that's
the lowest degree you can have which is
odd right some odd polynomials
are odd functions right some of them but
not
all of them right let's think about this
for example
y equals x plus one actually i don't
even need a y
x plus one okay if that's my polynomial
this is neither odd nor even right
like it's not it's not symmetrical about
the origin okay because it's been moved
up one
however if i just take that one off the
end
this is odd right and by extension
this is also odd and so on okay
so odd polynomials may
be odd okay
right maybe maybe
on functions okay
but there is no way
no possible way that an odd polynomial
we could twist and and turn it to make
it an even function
right can you see why um they may be
odds
functions okay they might not be but
they may
not be even functions
okay not ever it will break it you won't
actually be
even because when you got this um degree
here right which is one
when you put in a minus sign okay it's
never going to be equal to itself
with a positive value or vice versa okay
the positive value will never be equal
to the negative one
now taking this idea and thinking about
even polymers then right
even polynomials
you can see where this is going right
let's think of some um the the classic
even function that you first learn about
is x squared
right x squared that's even
okay but x squared
plus 1 is not even sorry take that back
x squared plus 1 is even but if i
change it a little different way let's
say
it's type of minus x on the end let's
factorize that to see what it would look
like that's x
x minus one right so the roots are at
zero and one so it's been moved over
okay so that's no longer even
does that make sense yes that's not even
but actually we just said right
if i move it up or down that's still
okay right
because it still has that reflection of
symmetry
okay now let's just um before we take a
conclusion out of this and try and
generalize right even polynomials
in the same ways are polymers right they
may be even functions
okay or they may not be but in just the
same ways we have this problem with odd
functions right
there's no way you can have an even
polynomial and have it be an
odd function okay because when you if
you've got you know
power two power four power six when you
square it out
your negatives and your positives it
won't matter whether they're negative or
positive okay
so you're always going to go towards
even this and not oddness right
um they may not be
well maybe i should say they cannot be
that's a better way to say it
okay you probably draw a nice sneak venn
diagram for this if you like brown we'll
love it we'll skip it for now
and how can i generalize and um how can
i see
is a pattern here why can i add one or
5 or -100 or whatever but i can't
add or subtract an x or 2x or a 3x or
anything like that
well let's consider an example let's um
let's up the degree this time okay let's
go to say a cubic okay
now if we consider a general cubic yeah
that's going to be
ax cubed bx squared i don't know what
any of these
coefficients actually are okay now
because it's a cubic
odd degree right it might be odd
but it might not be right let's consider
as
as if it is okay
okay now if it's odd this is the
condition
for an odd function right so therefore i
ought to be able to take all of these
and evaluate them in terms of these two
lines okay
so i'm going to say f of minus x
let's every x let's replace it with a
minus x okay
i'm going to get a let's write it a log
hand just to make sure we don't confuse
our signs here
right b
c and the d is independent right
well that's equal to the whole original
polynomial with the minus sign at the
front okay so every single term all four
of them
they turn negative okay so this is going
to be minus ax cubed
minus bx squared minus cx minus 3.
okay so far so good so this is just the
definition of
an odd function yes i should say that
sorry
okay all right but i can i can do some
evaluating over here right
this is actually minus a x cubed because
that there's three negatives
into one negative here that's
b x squared right
is that okay people think yeah okay i
just saw people
with confused faces so i didn't wonder
if i was doing something wrong okay
that's what i've got my left hand side
right um this
has gone positive this never had a next
term on it so it stays positive yep
um on the right hand side
stop stop what what's the left-hand side
the left-hand side corresponds to this
um
i've i've been i've substituted in minus
x that's why i've got all these minus
x's here
okay whereas this side is that yeah okay
so i've i've switched those around
but hopefully the minus x is there makes
it unambiguous which ones which
is that all right
almost there what's that okay wait do
people want me to stop before i go any
further
this side is f minus x or actually it's
p
of minus x okay whereas this
is um minus p of x
is that okay yeah all right great let's
keep going
now uh i can finish writing out this
sign
okay but because of the way the signs
are you can see i've got a minus ax
cubed here
and one here as well and i've got a
minus cx here and i've got one here as
well
okay so you add those terms to both
sides they just disappear and in the
same way just to keep everything
positive
right i can add a bx squared and a d
to both sides and that'll make this side
equal to zero is that okay
so when i add to both sides here's what
i end up with two b x squared plus two d
that's equal to 0. because i've got 0 on
this side i can just divide through
by 2. so i get this
now what that tells you if you come back
to your original
polynomial right is that those
terms there right they actually don't
exist they're trivial
really what i've got is this okay
now can you see why this works can you
see why this makes sense not just
algebraically
but of course we should have expected
this right
why is it that uh here we go
these these functions here right these
two are odd
but this one's not okay these two are
odd because the only part that
makes them up right they're odd but when
i add this one
one is well one's a kind of function is
it it's an even function isn't it
so on plus even is is no longer
odd okay now if i've got these parts
here
x squared terms will always be even and
constant terms will also
always be even okay if i want the whole
thing to be odd i've got to get rid of
those even parts okay and only leave
behind the odd ones right which is why
that's what you end up with at the end
okay
now you can rehearse this argument if i
said uh
let's change the degree make it say four
or six
or eight and let it be an even function
okay you're going to get the same result
but what are you going to expect
if say
if this is the um sorry a let's make it
to the power of 4.
okay if i told you that this one i
should change the name
if q were even right it couldn't
possibly be odd obviously because you've
got a four out the front
but if q were even in just the same way
that making it odd
i had to get rid of all the even terms
okay
to make sure that this is really even
i've got to get rid of all the odd terms
out
okay so if it's even
then what i'm really going to be left
with is this term
that's okay but this terms out
this squared term is okay this one's out
and
there's my constant on the end okay so
if i want the whole thing to be even
then all my components have to be even
as well
okay right now the reason why i drew
attention to this
is because in exercise 4d
i think question 12
c 12c
12c says p of x
is an odd polynomial
and it has degree three
okay and then it tells you some
information about um things that are
factors
and things that when you divide them
through you get certain remainders okay
and you have to find what p is right
well
you only get given two pieces of
information um you get told that
x plus 4 is a factor x plus 4 is a
factor so
using the factor theorem what can i
write down what equation can i write
down
if x plus 4 is a factor p of minus 4
is 0. good the other piece of
information is when it's divided by
x minus three
x minus three the remainder is 21. so
with the remainder theorem what can i
write
okay good so i've got two equations here
so therefore
in order to really be able to solve this
and find out you know what is p
there can only be two unknowns two
variables because we've got two
equations right
now obviously if you just start out with
ax q plus bx squared
and so on you've got four unknowns you
can't do it so you've got to be able to
recognize this
okay so i would say since p of x is odd
it is in the form
and then you just take the odd
components
okay i'd still call them a and c rather
than a and b
because it gets a bit confusing which
one you're talking about okay
and then you just take these and you
solve it like you normally would okay
two unknowns two equations off you go
does that make sense
okay so some of the trickier questions
um in that 4d exercise toward the end
they're deliberately going after this
idea so
if you i mean i think in some senses
because like we mentioned
you've covered odd neighbor functions
before you already knew what this
definition was
some of you might have gotten here on
your own steam but if you're a little
confused
how can i possibly work out what abc and
vr this is what you need
okay